oh yeah I told you that time I was
trick-or-treating with me and my friends
kid and we were all all of us there guy
sticks a [ __ ] you know the kind of
long saw used to you you cut branches
yeah
sticks that out of the [ __ ] sticks it
out of the door
I'll blade what do you mean you stuck a
[ __ ] blade out like with trigger
trainees off a real blade and then I go
I go I grab both of them that blade
right there I go viral what are they in
the woman came out and said you
shouldn't trick-or-treat oh the for
shipping trick-or-treating houses I
don't know about really and I said I'll
murder you I'll murder in the shake come
at me I said we should call the cops but
then I would for sure
that's what he n yeah stuck that out so
strange with little children how about I
kill you how about I kill all of you in
that house castilo tells her where you
stay in your hotel when you come in the
city is everything for me and for me
palms triggers negative thoughts right
because that's where I lost a roid
Nelson there so don't get me the palms
go hey shop we'll give you our master
suite I would rather stay at Circus
Circus
that's very interesting remember I lost
the fight to stay two more days and do
[ __ ] stuff with ultimate fighters
miserable it's so man as you're walking
around on a Sunday at Palms when no
one's in the [ __ ] casino and you lost
the Beast by your life and you had to
walk through people in the few people or
they're recognize you of course by the
way of course you lost you've been
fighting a year yeah fighting Roy Nelson
a hilarious you've been fighting a year
and they put you in with that ridiculous
veteran a sign up one of the 100 UFC
Hall of Famer actually yeah legitimately
mmm a Hall of Famer you'd say best chin
maybe I would say right Jones in some
ways yeah Roy Johnson right Road Chin's
right now everyone out now so Joe has
chins of all-time and a ridiculously
good fighter I mean what if if but
here's what's funny about that that
fight when it got sanctioned if it was a
regular fight of course only really got
st. chance cuz we're at a tournament and
Vegas sanction it but I love if we let's
say the I just got the UFC which I went
with three fights say I only had three
fights
I got do UFC all right here's Roy Nelson
Commission's when I caught up
this guy's over 30 fights you have this
kid s3 that's pretty insane chin it but
then boxing they would never let that
happen
no but that's just the nature of the
beast but it also it gave me my platform
you know I get to take one on the chin
literally or behind the air about
knockout and he did that to so many
people you just don't see it yeah I do
because I I'm looking for the overhand
right but yeah you don't see that if I'm
out you're looking for dude huh you know
what you're looking for and I answer
said my hands are out that's all I
stepped back this 27 year old man had a
gun on in his front pocket it got
triggered and went through his nutsack
into his thigh and before going to the
hospital to get stitched up he had his
girlfriend drive him to his friend's
house to drop off the gun he's a
convicted felon with 13 felonies so he
couldn't get caught with having a gun
while he was in the hospital getting
stitched up this article says that
somehow a balloon filled with weed
slipped out of his butthole while he was
getting stitched up okay they reported
it to the police while he was there
finishing up on him police searched his
car found a pair of jeans that were
bloodied up they're suspecting that it's
the pair of jeans that he accidentally
shot himself in and had a baggie of meth
inside
they'd been real winner yeah they then
arrested him and while they were taking
him in another balloon field of
marijuana fell out of his ass oh my god
they keep saying that it slipped out
yeah well he probably used the
lubrication your rump gets loose you bet
I feel a little too relaxed a little
relaxed and balloon it's hilarious I saw
I did a food-truck Diaries Michelle
Waterson and she was Stan your B&B and
she was it's her she's there for their
husband you're sweet and this is she was
ah there's a there's a picture of you
and Brian at the house ago oh yeah she
goes yeah which one she goes uh
you know how sweet she goes but brian
has his [ __ ] in your face oh there's
probably go when I went and I didn't
scare me I went which one
more than one I'm sure which one is it
she was uh always it on the beach he was
yelling oh yeah Brian's like throwing
his dick at me she was yeah oh yeah
that's a great picture those are a lot
of photoshop like say hey see if you can
bring that up it's a real joy Allah took
that picture with joep picture oh you
would start when you guys were first
dating that's right
damn bro long time ago knows what I
could jump I was probably 45 but I was
that I think it was 45 years old when I
did that for real I was 40 proud no it's
just it's just weird that I was there it
is oh so obviously my girl took that Wow
somebody superimposed no that was me
that's what he's really do some way you
know sure I said to him - I feel like
I'm gonna jump really high right now
hey ah God has a perfect picture look at
that she did it with her chin she's like
like God I was like what the [ __ ] good
hops right there and I'm not mad when I
dance when I did ballet in theater
school
well that's very bad it was the first
time I realize I can't jump super high
because I would jump and do all I could
do all the tours are tasing seven I was
just she was like the woman has next me
from Ethiopia she goes you jumps so high
I was like yeah it's news to me I guess
I what's great about that picture is
that it's not a fighting picture because
you don't like what move are you about
to do yes go in [ __ ] first where did I
get those zoomed up in shorts I like
them yeah where'd you get those dude you
were so much Lou you're shaved head how
[ __ ] I was still fighting or are you
still fighting yeah yeah man I tried to
watch UFC the other night on ESPN yeah
and I just couldn't do it you couldn't
figure it out
no any law well one it was so violent oh
yeah that this guy was getting pummeled
and they kept going to the doctor and
then the guys in the announcers like
he's got a skin a piece of flap oh you
know skin flat and I was and then the
doctor let him still fighting I was like
he's pretty intense yeah I was just a so
bloody I just end up thing to Rogen I
said man this is too much you know and
he said I've seen worse and I was like I
can't even imagine yeah it's pretty
brutal so you've never been in I don't
you invented villains in your life to
help you succeed like I've done that
good morning like I have to admit you
know I mean every morning here's a
villain list waiting but I think that
like unfortunately though for like say
like for female comics or female
actresses like you know the villain it's
easy to pick a villain as the villain is
there so it's all men yeah you know like
because you know we're not getting a
chance it's not that when you're holding
me back but but but it's it's kind of
work what a great motivation they like
to like you know I mean they got Captain
Marvel out of it yeah we know it's a
good movie what are you talking about I
might captivated you feminist so you're
not with your girl anymore no yeah we're
so in love that's my boo that is my boy
did I see that it was pretty extreme
time anytime our experiences at anytime
we have a friend who's like this is my
girl and I love her any songs like oh
that bad huh
are you trying to convince anybody is
talking much we love each other every
time I meet a woman no I could never
imagine cheating I would so in love it's
like the marketing about two weeks yeah
yeah it's just relationships are tough
too when you're in this business to when
you're like this business when you're
like you know you very masculine I guess
to like nobody teaches us how to [ __ ]
talk to each other yeah man we don't
want no you know just about like men to
men women like like I watched you with
like you were getting he was in an
argument with his brother and Brendan
Brendan will get in your face
excuse me sir you're not doing it to
bully you're just you're you're just I
wouldn't do it anyone I did you're
making your point yeah but
subconsciously no no I disagree with you
subconsciously he for sure is bullying
so consciously it's like he's not bully
though I know I'm not sick yeah but I
mean subconsciously yes you're huge and
you're you know you're like I know what
I'm fine our self doing that with like
you know and you can't do that with like
my cuff was said can I do with certain
people yeah you're you're on like
all right okay then you have to think it
didn't have to be like you have to check
Brenda doesn't like when you so so we
were playing when me Brenda didn't know
iliza shlesinger we were playing
volleyball and allies
she is your prophet even better she was
not very good and I saw his face stop
and he looked at Tony who's also an
Olympian yeah Olympic boxer and his face
is I just buy good things I just because
we have to be a great couple
I'm he's fish
no no because she knows that it she
would know how to get you out you're
ready to do well in that audition oh oh
maybe because you're lazy and you know
the fans are there to see her not my
dummy dead-ass yeah and I go ladies and
Joan
she's the best female comic on the
planet give it up for iliza shlesinger
and she got up there with I'm like you
know I'm just trying to walk out she
goes excuse me female oh I was like as
soon as she went that I just I was like
oh god oh sorry
I felt like such a date they pick
anything you could have said anything
she's such a beast so I should have said
I just said she's one of the best
comedians on the planet does she matter
what she is I thought I was giving her a
big comment it seemed the best female on
the planet which I do think she is yeah
but you can I'm sure you have a list of
dudes that use you would think of
funnier than her I love her you know how
many of my female friends that I know
they'll hit me but female friends hit me
up about two people okay two people if I
first of all I'm sick of in LA if you
meet a hot girl in LA yeah and you tell
you do call me her first question is do
you know Chris D'Elia okay so that's
getting on my [ __ ] nerves
okay
okay so I'm sick of that thing and the
other one is they love Eliza yeah you
know but what I'm saying is why the Nile
she said yes yes the bull bull bull
she's too killer no but like if you're
in your mind you were you were you know
you had a list you said okay well you
know well who's my top ten female comics
you know but that's the way we have Best
Actress Best Actor that's right we have
female sports in male sport and I did
that it's that NBA snap LeBron to
Bethany we're not doing that yeah I mean
we have we separated on price now in
different life we do that in life so go
[ __ ] yourself I didn't I'm saying you
know you say something like you know